hey everyone it's Mike from orderflows
and welcome back to my channel in this
video I'll be talking about orderflows
gaps and what a orderflow gap is it's a
sign of a market moving quickly and it
could often result in good trading
opportunities and before we jump into it
again you know if you haven't subscribed
to the channel be sure you subscribe to
the channel hit that notification Bell
so anytime I post a new video um you
know you'll be notified of it so let's
uh jump into orderflow gaps now an
orderflow Gap occurs when there's a gap
between the value areas of two
consecutive bars on a footprint chart
and what it represents is basically an
imbalance in value right and it often
indicates you know a market that's
moving you know pretty quickly now what
you see here on the on the screen is
just a normal volume footprint chart
right and you know over the years I've
added tools to my footprint chart right
the orderflows trader and one of the
tools that I added was the value areas
in a bar right you know if you're
familiar with volume profile Market
profile you you understand what the
value area is it's the area where um 70%
of the volume trades and you know
whether you're looking at a day time
frame or you know a one hour uh it
doesn't matter right because really what
you're looking for is that concentration
of volume which in turns creates value
and you could go down to you know a
smaller time frame I like to look at it
on a Barby bar basis actually and what
we have here is a setting for the value
area right I'll just enable it and you
can see um when it's enabled okay what
it looks like on a bar by bar basis now
I'm I'm just looking at uh 10 years
right it's it's because it's uh easier
to I show you on on the chart with the
10 years let me get the crosshairs up
here and right so you can see each bar
has a value area right this value area
is set to 70% so the value area is this
either the green box on green up candles
or this red box on red Down Candles or
if it's a doe bar it still has a valary
but just colored gray that's just for me
to highlight that hey you know what the
bar is a dogee bar and open and closed
at the same price and you can see areas
in here gaps between say this uh these
two green bars right the value area high
of this first green bar and the value
area low of the second green bar just as
you have another one here you got
another little Gap here between this uh
value area low of this red bar and this
value area high of this other Red Bar
and you know it wasn't until I started
looking at the value
areas sort of on a Barby bar basis that
things really started to you
know I say click but you know make more
sense right and there's different ways
you can trade uh the value areas and
then I'll cover those in in different
videos but really what I want to talk
about today are the gaps in value okay
and and you know just just really
briefly you know in the past you know 10
years ago you know I I started adding
the value areas into my trading um on a
bar by bar basis probably within the
last uh five years so prior to that
really what I spent a lot of time
focusing on was the uh point of control
in the bar point of control is the most
volume but it you know it wasn't it was
just the most volume at a price in the
bar okay whereas the value area sort of
takes it a step further and it helps you
to create you know value and just really
quickly you can see this area here right
where we're going sideways value areas
are basically overlapping um you know
here they're overlapping this bar this
bar these two bars these two bars
they're overlapping right they're they
they cover the same area it's when you
have a gap between say this bar and this
bar that it's starting to tell you
something values moving away from your
established value area okay and you know
in the past you know just looking at it
when I would just look at the simple um
footprint right with the value areas on
you know I could see that right but I I
wanted I went back to my programmer you
know this is a nice thing right see I I
created the orderflows trader to help me
in my own trading and I put all these
tools in there to help you in your
trading right I just don't go out there
um and copy a lot of the ideas off of
other Traders you know I'm I'm the one
that's um these designing this to help
me with my own trading right so that's
why I'm able to explain it right um in
detail so what you could do okay so
there this is the value areas right um
we have a tool on here it's called
orderflow
gaps okay so I'm just going to find it
in here orderflow
gaps click
enabled now you could also enable it
with a swing filter but you know I'll
just keep it on here so you can see this
red is that red it's magenta actually
this is a bearish order flow Gap this is
a bullish order flow Gap this is another
bullish order flow Gap right so you can
see how the market gapped down we were
basically going sideways here gaped down
went a little bit lower going sideways
now gapping up now here's the beauty
part of it right if you don't want to
even if you just want to clean it up a
bit more right take off the value
areas right because before to identify
the value area gaps you had
to have value areas
enabled so
now you don't need that right and you
can see here right here's the bearish
Gap right here here's the bullish Gap
here's the bullish Gap bullish Gap
bearish
bullish bullish bullish bearish okay we
got a bearish one forming right now
right
here so that's going to help you
identify these areas that you know
otherwise are going to go unnoticed to
you and imagine right if you can pick up
an area right just off the low of the
day this red line is the low of the day
where value is starting to migrate
higher
because you know if you've ever studied
Market profile volume profile you
understand the concept of value
migrating higher or lower once value
starts migrating higher or lower that is
the start of a potential Trend right and
you want to get in on
Trends as early as possible right and
and that's where identifying these gaps
in value are going to help you now don't
confuse the order flows gaps with fair
value gaps right U there there is
confusion um with that this is not an
ICT concept right I'm looking at the gap
between value arees right what ICT does
is that they're looking at the high of
you know it's over three bars they're
looking at the high of one bar the bar
one the low of bar three and you know if
they're not
overlapping in here then you know that's
a fair value Gap but it's different than
a fair value Gap right what an orderflow
Gap you know it's it's interesting
because you can only name these things
certain things right fair value Gap has
value and Gap in it whereas the order
flows Gap doesn't have the word value in
it but um sometimes Traders do get
confused and think that this is the same
thing as a fair value Gap and it's it's
not it's similar to it but you know it's
interesting because ICT they do use you
know the terms like when they see a fair
value Gap they say there's a market
imbalance okay but they're just looking
at a simple bar chart um you know we do
have a
tool let me just see
here let me pause this for a second and
find it on my chart all right here it is
this is the uh bar G Gap indicator okay
which is similar more a bit on the fair
value gaps right you can see here these
are bullish gaps these are bearish gaps
but this is different than the fair
value gaps that's a standalone indicator
this is actually built into the
footprint and again you know it's you
know orderflow is data points in the
market right
and it's more than just the volume
trading at the bid and the offer right
and and you know value is important as a
Trader right because you're going to be
looking at um you know where the volume
is
going right there's Al you know you hear
what com first the chicken or the egg
which moves first um price or value well
obviously price is going to go first but
it's going to pull up value and if
you're making value at subsequent higher
levels then you know those levels have a
stronger chance of holding if it's going
value is going up as opposed to just
price whereas if value is moving lower
together with price that's a good sign
that the Market's got some more um
movement to the downside all right so
again it's
uh on the overflows Trader software and
just really quick here let me pull up
the value areas really
quick okay here's
fixed now one other thing okay I I do
know it gets confusing right for some
Traders because they're going to say oh
you know there's this is where they get
confused is on the colors actually more
than anything else is like okay well
it's a green candle so you have a green
value area it's a red candle so you got
a red value area the Gap is going to be
blue or
magenta
and one thing that you can do I'll show
you here just really quick with The
Gap you can draw it out until
tested okay fixed is what I showed you
first I'm going to show you until
tested let me okay here I'll just show
you so this is what it looks like right
it's until tested and see here right
here when I have a
gap
that's you know the markk you know
people say how do you trade it well for
me I like the word you know the phrase
Gap and go I see the Gap I'm looking for
the market to go now you don't know the
Gap is going to form until the second
bar is trading and it's not going to be
confirmed until the bar is closed so
like right here you have a gap forming
but the bar is still trading mean who
knows this bar can turn up in here and
close the gap before it closes and the
Gap would disappear I like to wait for
the market to close or the bar rather to
close not the market but you see here
the Gap just disappeared as we traded up
into almost into that Gap so if it
trades back into the Gap the Gap will
disappear okay but once the bar finishes
this is a range chart so once that bar
finishes and if that Gap is there it
will stay there it's not going to
recolor or anything but you know I'm a
very visual person and that's the beauty
of you know a footprint chart is you can
see these gaps especially if you draw
them out you know until tested where how
strong it
is okay and again you know it's an area
that you can lean on especially if
you're coming back towards it right I
had talked about exhaustion prints um a
couple days ago right if I see I'm
coming down towards that Gap I got an
exhaustion print of nine here and then
you reverse up yeah this Gap is probably
holding right because Traders aren't
interested in selling it down into that
Gap to close that
Gap right but often times you know gaps
are going to be filled this Gap was
filled this Gap was filled this Gap
similar thing right we have the gap
trade back into that Gap literally where
the Gap is you have the exhaustion print
of one then the market reverses And
Trades higher well I got a feeling this
Gap is going to hold for now and you can
trade in that direction so you there's
different ways to trade gaps but this
gives you an idea of what you can do
with the orderflows trader software and
how you can understand the actual order
flow that's taking place in the market
better right because that's what
software should do just to help you
understand the market rather than just
plotting the market right because as a
Trader you want to understand what's
going
on all right so sorry guys I'm starting
to cough here so I'm going to end that
video now so again if you haven't
already be sure to subscribe to the
channel and and hit that like button and
the notification button and I'll see you
guys on the next video take care